today der 1 fc ssw kostet der scm mis
system am 2 august 2009 10 ist der
ehevertrag endgültig ausgelaufen
die usa und russland können somit ohne
jegliche einschränkung wieder
mittelstreckenraketen testen produzieren
und stationieren
in europa verbreitet sich die angst vor
einer massiven aufrüstung wie im kalten
krieg
aber wie ist das wirklich einzuschätzen
heute in vechta kompakt das ende des
vertrags um seine folgen
[Musik]
es war ein großer durchbruch als sich
michael gorbatschow und ronald reagan
1987 auf den ehevertrag einigten
das bewirkte ein weltweites
stationierung verbot von atomaren
landgestützten mittelstrecken raketen
mit einer reichweite von 500 bis 5500
kilometer bis 1991 wurden tatsächlich
846 us und 1846 sowjetische
trägersysteme und abschussvorrichtungen
vernichtet neue waffensysteme wurden
verboten
ursprünglich hatte die nato
mittelstreckenraketen eingeführt um den
warschauer pakt vor einer umfangreichen
invasion abzuschrecken
dieser hingegen wollte durch
mittelstreckenraketen seine militärische
durchschlagskraft erhöhen diese
szenarien hatten aber entweder 1980 er
jahre
aufgrund der entspannung zwischen ost
und west und der wirtschaftlichen
schwäche der sowjetunion an bedeutung
verloren
somit war auch der militär strategische
nutzen dieser raketensysteme hinfällig
man konnte hier getrost den vertrag
unterzeichnen und auch der begrenzung
konventionelle waffensysteme zustimmen
durch im letzten jahrzehnt haben sich
die geopolitischen und
militärstrategischen verhältnisse
deutlich geändert 19 87 gab es ein
politisches tauwetter zwischen der
damaligen sowjetunion und den usa
heute befinden wir uns im heftigen
globalen wettbewerb die spannungen
zwischen den großmächten nehmen
damit gehen regionale und globale
machtansprüche einher was wiederum die
militärische aufrüstung antreibt
mit china ist außerdem ein dritter
akteur dazu gekommen der von den
bisherigen rüstungskontrolle gar nicht
erfasst wird
denn sämtliche abkommen wurden nur
zwischen der sowjetunion beziehungsweise
russland und den usa geschlossen und
sind somit ein relikt des kalten krieges
sie reflektieren daher nicht die
geopolitische situation von 2009 10
so verfügt zum beispiel china über
einige hundert dieser
mittelstreckenraketen
sie sind ein zentraler bestandteil
seines waffenarsenals peking kann diese
systeme unbehindert und unkontrolliert
weiter ausbauen
daher dürften washington und moskau kein
interesse mehr am jene vertrag oder
anderen abkommen wie etwas tat zur
reduktion von langstreckenwaffen haben
denn diese bilateralen vereinbarungen
schränken ihre strategische
handlungsfreiheit ein während china
keinerlei auflagen unterliegt wenn der
herr derzeit über die stationierung
neuer mittelstreckenraketen spekuliert
wird dann steht vermutlich nicht der
europäische raum im vordergrund
zumindest die usa dürften hier mehr an
den westpazifik denken so hat washington
bereits unmittelbar nach dem auslaufen
des vertrags angekündigt konventionelle
mittelstreckenraketen in asien
positionieren zu wollen
immer mehr bedeutung erlangen dabei
seegestützte raketensysteme die welt
werde eingesetzt werden können
aber auch russland wird beim ausbau
seiner systeme neben dem europäischen
auch in asiatische szenario vor augen
haben mit dem ende des vertrags steigt
die angst dass wieder ein atomares
wettrüsten beginnt und abermals hunderte
atomraketen mitten in europa oder an
dessen rändern stationiert werden
tatsache ist dass die usa und nato seit
jahren ein raketenabwehrsystem in europa
forcieren und russland ist dabei seine
militärischen kapazitäten gegenüber
europa zu stärken
dazu gehört die stationierung von
raketen in kaliningrad vor allem aber
die massive aufrüstung auf der krim
damit soll vermutlich einerseits eine
drohkulisse gegenüber europa aufgebaut
und andererseits der
anspruch auf eigene einflusssphären
demonstriert werden eine neuerliche
aufstellung atomarer
mittelstreckenraketen ist daher nicht
von der hand zu weisen
allerdings gibt es von us-seite bisher
keine konkreten absichtserklärungen dazu
die reaktionen europäischer staaten sind
widersprüchlich zu unterstützen zwar die
nato-länder die vertragsauflösung durch
das weiße haus es mehren sich aber auch
kritische stimmen insbesondere in
deutschland die vor einer neuerlichen
raketenstationierung bahnen ein kurzes
resümee das ende des mietvertrags ist
zwar höchst bedauerlich es hat aber
vorerst keine unmittelbaren auswirkungen
auf die sicherheit in europa sollte aber
zum beispiel der kreml beabsichtigen
seinen einfluss in osteuropa im
schwarzmeerraum und im nahen osten auch
militärisch zu untermauern so wäre
mittelstreckenraketen ein wesentliches
element des strategischen kalküls anders
ausgedrückt der drohende einsatz dieser
waffensysteme sollte dann europa davon
abhalten sich dem russischen streben
entgegenzustellen
ein ausblick die weitere entwicklung
wird davon abhängen wie sich das
verhältnis zwischen den usa und russland
aber auch zwischen der eu und russland
gestaltet im falle einer entspannung
wäre die gefahr neuer stationierungen
sicher deutlich reduziert andernfalls
werden die usa nicht zögern gemeinsam
mit den europäischen verbündeten ein
neues raketensystem in europa aufzubauen
[Musik]